les bestioles mystérieuse de la france
qui sont-elles pourquoi le cerveau a
besoin d'avoir peur d'elle
quelle histoire cette cache derrière
tous ces monstres légendes contes
réalité ou alors juste tonton michel
tuer il a fait une blague et justes a
mal tourné et du coup on ya tous cru
quand on part du dix septième siècle
jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour voir les
histoires des six bêtes et créatures qui
ont fait le plus flipper les français à
travers le temps loïc il eu lieu l'une
des premières bestioles mystérieuse et
répertoriés en france et la bête du
cinglé qu'on appelle aussi la bête de
caen maintenant je dirais ça c'est sûr
elle apparaît pour la première fois dans
la forêt de cinglais le 10 mars 1632
genre on a vraiment le jour on a presque
l'heure ces cinglés c'est à quelques
kilomètres au sud de caen et à partir de
cette date là une quinzaine de personnes
se font dévorer en moins d'un mois et là
on se dit tiens michel il se passe
quelque chose je crois toujours
les habitants du village ne parle que de
ça ils comprennent pas trop et il se
réfugie un peu dans les croyances en
imaginant que c'est un démon ou un
maléfice qui a été lancée sur tout le
village pour les pillards de quelque
chose au mois de juin de l'année
suivante
on dénombre une trentaine de nouvelles
victimes donc la bête se nourrit un peu
trop au point de vue des habitants qui
flippe un peu quand même parce que
rappelons le il se demande toujours s'il
s'agit vraiment d'un animal ou d'une
force maléfique qui s'abat sur eux
l'ordre est alors donnée de rameuter
cinq à six mille personnes pour
organiser genre une immense battus ils
réussissent à rassembler environ 3000
personnes qui ratisse tout la forêt avec
un seul objectif on trouve la bête et on
la fume
c'est à dire est là et c'est ça qui est
surprenant c'est exactement ce qui se
passe
trois jours plus tard avec un coude
arquebuses la bête du cinglé et tu es
donc elle existait vraiment en gros elle
a été décrite comme étant un grand
dogues une sorte de loup un peu plus
longs plus roux là que pointues et la
croupe plus large que d'habitude la bête
était apparemment hyper âge il est hyper
rapide donc rien à voir avec ton oncle
michel de la bête de beaune et l'une des
plus meurtrières de l'histoire de france
apparaît 60 ans après celle de caen et
un siècle avant la célèbre bête du
gévaudan qu'on évoquera après tout à
l'heure elle apparaît pour la première
fois en touraine au mois de février 1900
1693 c'est fou à chaque fois d'avoir les
dates comme ça des récits c'est parce
qu'il n'y avait pas internet à l'époque
donc un petit clavier on était un petit
clavier un petit carnet les gens noté
dans un petit carré non mais c'est fou
c'est intéressant cette vidéo tu vas
lalique et toi moi je vais m'abonner
donc en février 1693 le 19 février
précisément on retrouve le corps d'un
petit garçon de 9 ans pierre boiro
violemment déchiqueté dans la commune de
saint patrice et dans cette région qui
est très boisée où il ya plein de
glandes et c'est malheureusement une
attaque de loup ça choque personne ça
passe un peu inaperçu
et là aussi ça aurait dû être le cas si
cinq jours plus tard y avait pas une
nouvelle attaque on retrouve le corps en
morceaux de la jeune antoinette ses
tanks a été retrouvé par sa mère dans
les landes du compte 1 voir justement au
mois de mars de la même année à beaune
et deux nouvelles victimes sont à
déplorer mais cette fois c'est des
adultes les mois suivants c'est une
jeune fille de 17 ans qui tombe sous les
crocs de la bête en juin thomas su 2 me
mimo ah bah non mais c'est comme la
station de métro c'est me moroni
miromesnil et bien voilà lui tomasz eu
de miromesnil intendant de la province
de touraine annonce qu'en quelques mois
il ya déjà eu plus de 70 personnes de
tués et plus de 70 personnes de blessés
c'est vraiment énorme ya des témoins qui
disent qu'ils ont vu la créature et au
vu des détails qui sont donnés par ces
personnes la majorité des habitants se
l'imaginent comme une créature
diabolique et monsieur de biro mesnil
organise alors débattue lui aussi qui
s'avère ce coup-ci inefficace et à la
fin du mois de novembre 2693 un total de
160 habitants supplémentaires que
s'offrent la bête abonnés directement
reliée aux alentours ça commence à faire
beaucoup
sans surprise les habitants nous ferons
plus du tout dans le bois ils ont peur
d'être le prochain déjeuner de la
créature et il ya les processions qui se
multiplient les prières pour espérer que
la créature diabolique disparaissent et
c'est ce qui va au mois d'août 1694 les
meurtres s'arrête aussi rapidement
qu'ils ont commencé il ya le curé de
varennes qui annonce que 250 personnes
ont péri sous les coups les crocs les
morsures les griffures de la bête en
moins d'un an et demi et personne n'a
aujourd'hui le fin mot de l'histoire et
peut définitivement dire qu'ils étaient
le ou les auteurs de tous et meurent
parce que c'était vraiment une bête ou
par on ne sait pas et du coup on sera
jamais à priori
[Applaudissements]
troisième bête 1731 sud d'auxerre près
du bois de trucy sainte violent il ya un
jeune garçon de 12 ans qui travaillait
avec sa mère soudain il ya un animal qu
apparaît qu'ils y tiens je vais dévorer
ce jeune garçon la mer arrive à extirper
des crocs de la bestiole son fils et il
court un peu au village enfin son fils
ils courent pas tellement pour expliquer
ce qui s'est passé donc la maman porte
son gamin court vers le village pour
essayer de le sauver mais
malheureusement le garçon décède sur le
chemin il s'agit de la première victime
de la bête de trucy où la bête de
l'auxerrois suite à cette attaque
il y en a encore plein d'autres au point
que cette affaire là elle arrive
jusqu'aux oreilles du roi louis 15 qui
valaient jusqu'à offrir une prime aux
courageux qui arriverait à tuer cette
bête là donc on prend la sphère genre
hyper au sérieux bond toujours la même
solution il ya des battus qui sont
faites et dense est battu il ya de
nombreux loup qui sont tués malgré le
fait que la manière d'agir de cette bête
n'a rien à voir avec la méthode de
chasse dingue mais malgré tout ça il ya
toujours deux jeunes enfants qui sont
les principales victimes de la créature
qui continuent d'être attaquée de
manière régulière la même une nourrice
qui s'est aventuré à essayer de retirer
un enfant pareil de la gueule de la
créature et dans les textes qu'on a
trouvé les écrits qu'elle aurait
récupéré que ses pieds donc ça commence
à être un petit peu choquant ça fait
cinq mois que ça dure et il ya le curé
de velde merci qui qui annonce qu'il ya
un total de 14 morts fin 1734 les
victimes atteignent le nombre de 28 à la
même période de loose ont abattu hélas
les horreurs 16 direct mais on peut se
dire aussi que c'est un hasard c'est à
dire que tu mérites zeppelin d'action
donc le moment où ça s'arrête c'est pas
certain que la dernière action qui a été
menée soit celle qui a mis fin
ça peut être aussi un espèce de biais de
causalité en tout cas les habitants des
villages tente de justifier les meurtres
en accusant quoi qu'il arrive les loups
temps à d'autres qui parlent de loups
garous d'autres encore qui parle de
démons là aussi l'affairé pas tranché
la bête du gévaudan
alors elle a fait la une de tous les
magazines et les espèces de gazette qui
avait à cette époque c'est la star des
grosses bestioles en france on lui a
même consacré plusieurs films et elle a
causé la mort d'une centaine de
personnes ce qui reste en dessous de la
bête de bd par contre celle ci je vais
vous la faire courte parce qu'elle
mériterait à elle seule un dossier de
cinq pages dans un magazine tellement
elle est passionnante et ça tombe bien
michel c'est exactement ce qu'on a fait
dans le prochain numéro de curieuses
c'est l'histoire passionnante d'une
créature qui va mobiliser les forces
royales qui va alimenter les rumeurs les
croyances la presse va publier des
centaines d'articles sur le sujet en
quelques mois et même les autres pays
vont en parler et en même temps se
moquer des français qui n'arrivent pas à
gérer ça il ya l'église qui a va jusqu'à
faire une annonce officielle dans
laquelle elle affirme que la bête est
ici pour punir dépêché en gros ça
nourrit tous les fantasmes de l'époque
et je vous laisserai découvrir
directement ça dans le prochain numéro
de curieuses pour en savoir plus vous
avez les infos à la fin de cette vidéo
la bête du verrou en 1799 puisque on
avance dans le temps aux environs du
village de pallier ce qui est pas loin
de gévaudan et du viaduc de millau qui
n'existait pas à l'époque le hic
parce qu'il avait pas été construit il
ya des enfants qui jouent à côté d'un
arbre
ils aperçoivent un animal et ils vont le
décrire comme étant plus mince qu'un
loup à la tête au museau d'une sorte de
gros lévriers et khâgne incroyable
agilité les enfants se réfugient dans
l'arbre mais la bête est assez rapide
pour prendre l'un d'eux pierre jean qui
alors âgée de 6 ans des hommes qui
travaillaient pas loin sur un chantier
ou je sais pas quoi rattraper la
créature parce qu'ils entendent avec le
beau etc
et à force de la course et du faire peur
et où ils l'obligent à lâcher son butin
donc le jeune garçon mais il est en très
mauvais état et il répond à rien faire
il a les boyaux à l'air c'est trop tard
la bête apparaît dans les villages en
pleine journée
ce qui est différent des autres
bestioles qui attaquent souvent la nuit
ou qui attaquent en forêt loin loin de
l'activité humaine
là elle se montre hyper visible elle
s'attaque surtout aux jeunes enfants
elle qui elle prend d'abord le foie pour
ensuite s'attaquer aux membres et 15
jours plus tard la bête s'attaque à un
autre enfant
le frère de l'enfant effrayés par la
bête qui s'est redressée devant lui va
chercher de l'aide à vero mais il est
trop tard et son frère est retrouvé mort
peu de temps après c'est une jeune fille
qui se fait attaquer on remarque donc
que la bête ne s'attaque pas aux adultes
et plusieurs personnes ont eu la chance
entre guillemets de l'observer et disent
qu'elles ressemblent un peu un chien
mais que quand ils vont pour la caresser
celle-ci d'étaler mais en gros ça
n'attaquez pas l'adulte par contre elle
elle les fuyait donc il y avait un
espèce de bail de s'attaquer un peu aux
proies faciles le curé du village de
saint-andré a même juré avoir entendu
son cri est dit que ça ressemble un peu
aux braiment dindane
je veux le braiment donald maintenant
loïc et peut-être loupé sur internet
maintenant
on s'assoit semblait même des
braconniers ont tenté de la chasser mais
il y en a un qui a réussi à lui tirer
dessus
il a dit qu'elle s'était rouler au sol
et quelles qu'elles étaient parties
qu'elles avaient déguerpi à une vitesse
hallucinante
après quelques mois la bête de véro a
disparu d'un coup encore une fois il ya
l'un des habitants qui a émis
l'hypothèse que c'était peut-être une
hyène il ya le curé qui pensaient que
c'était aussi peut-être un lynx et au
final c'était peut-être un loup cervier
c'est un lynx du nord de l'europe
bon d'autres qui pencherait plus pour
l'hypothèse du loup garou mais faut
quand même se rappeler qu'à cette époque
on connaît moins toutes les toutes les
espèces animalières et tous les tous les
prédateurs ou tous les charognards qui
existe et donc on pouvait aussi
construire facilement une légende sur
une bête qu'on n'avait jamais vu gros
saut dans le temps pour arriver en 1946
c'est pas loin d'aujourd'hui avec la
baisse du ca y est depuis le mois de
septembre
very soir est une bête sanguinaire qui
se nourrit de chèvres de moutons du
bétail etc
y compris d'ailleurs des chiens des
taureaux n'importe quel animal qu'elle
croise sais pas où nous sommes en
auvergne la guerre vient juste de se
terminer du coup et la viande c'est un
bien qui est très très rare du coup ça
pose un vrai problème et les autorités
prennent ça vraiment à bras le corps les
forces de l'orde actuels en sont même
parfois obligés de confisquer le bétail
des agriculteurs pour réussir à nourrir
la population alors il ya des écoliers
qui parle d'un gros chien d'autres qui
parlent d'un loup on parle aussi parfois
d'un tigre qui aurait d'énormes pat
toole ou encore c'est une hypothèse de
panthère dont il serait question il ya
plein de témoignages mais ils sont si
variés que la chasse à l'ours est
déclaré dans l'une des communes
c'est vraiment on sait pour le plus
intéressant c'est le témoignage d'un
agriculteur qui dit qu'il a battu une
bête à la tête de fouine aux oreilles
pointues à la queue très longue et au
pelage de panthère il ya la presse qui
reçoit ce témoignage et ont conclu alors
qu'il pourrait s'agir d'une jeunette
c'est une sorte de carnassiers africains
que vous voyez peut-être juste ici parce
qu'au final il n'a pas abattu de la
juste blessé et la tension est tellement
forte qu'il ya un jour il ya de jeunes
qui sont pris de panique parce qu'il ya
un animal qui s'approche d'eux
qui se balade ils vont aller voir les
chasseurs du coin ils disent il faut
absolument tuer cette grosse bête qui va
nous tuer ils le tuaient c'étaient juste
leur propre chien en fait en réalité
donc on est passif quand on est dehors
une autre hypothèse qui est assez
probable
il ya certains qui pensent qu'en fait
c'est un groupe de maquisards qui sont
toujours cachées et qui tue le bétail
pour simplement se nourrir mais
l'histoire se termine finalement 1951
lorsqu'on affirme avoir tué cette baisse
ce serait un grand demi encore lui et la
bête de ca y est resté au singulier mais
son oeuvre est en réalité signé
d'attaqués de loups pour la population
de l'époque ce serait exactement ça qui
s'est passé comme d'habitude il ya
d'autres hypothèses ce serait une meute
de chiens ou encore l'yonne échappé
d'une ménagerie qui était alors près de
limoges
je voudrais qu'on s'arrête deux secondes
sur sur la relation entre l'homme et le
loup il ya de nombreuses autres
créatures qu'on évoque ailleurs dans le
prochain curieuse mais pourquoi le loup
c'est l'animal qui se trouve l'un des
premiers cités dans ce genre d'affaires
sanguinolente le loup est apparue il ya
environ 50 millions d'années il fait
partie de la famille des canidés ils
chassent la plupart du temps du petit
gibier et c'est un animal j'allais dire
craintif c'est pas tellement craintif
mais il se méfier ils approchent pas
facile du coup on pourrait s'étonner que
toutes ces bêtes se souvent comparé à un
animal qui est plutôt farouche face à
l'homme parce que l inverse on a une
relation avec le loup ya même des
peintures préhistoriques qui
représentent eux des hommes qui chassent
à côté des loups on a trouvé des
ossements de l'animal dans des tombeaux
humains dans des très vieux tombeau
humain donc la cohabitation semblait se
passer correctement jusqu'à ce qu'un
jour l'homme se disent je vais élever
des animaux pour les manger et à partir
de là l'entente entre le loup et l'homme
devient un peu problématique parce qu en
fait l'homme il invente une nouvelle
règle il dit à son pote cloud
ces animaux ils sont à moi en fait donc
si tu les manges tu me vole et tu dois
le comprendre mais c'est l'homme qui a
imposé cette règle de posséder les
choses du coup dès le début du moyen-âge
le loup devient synonyme de danger et de
cruauté parce qu'ils volent le bétail et
c'est très sanglant etc etc c'est le
loup qui décime les troupeaux et les
hommes se mettent à créer et à raconter
des récits un peu fou mêlant l'homme et
le loup est aujourd'hui encore le lourd
reste représentée dans les contes et les
histoires pour enfants comme l'animal
féroce 110 blanc qui veulent mal c'est
un peu le bouc émissaire facile dans
l'esprit des hommes le loup est donc
celui qui vole la nourriture par le sang
il est devenu l'ennemi numéro 1 des
éleveurs de bétail qui a fini par
devenir celui que nous connaissons tous
comme le grand méchant loup donc c'est
pas c'est pas si anormal que ça qu'à
chaque fois qu'il ya une bête féroce qui
attaquent on se dit ça doit être un bon
je vous le disais également au début de
la vidéo le nouveau numéro de son
magazine mensuel kernews se rend
décembre c'est le numéro 9 vous êtes
déjà plus de dix mille elle recevoir
tous les mois vaut 52 pages dans votre
boîte aux lettres ou en version
numérique
donc merci d'avoir suivi ce projet si
vous voulez ce magazine de curiosité le
mentalisme l'abonnement est à partir de
1 euro 65 par mois frais de port inclus
moins cher qu'un seul sur twitch est
plus intéressant qu'un type i puisque
vous recevez durant un an 10 magazines
chez vous directement vous pourrez lire
quelques pages sur le site c'est en
descriptions et bien sûr vous pouvez
vous inscrire rapidement via le lien
aussi un description pour recevoir votre
premier numéro de votre abonnement à
partir du numéro de décembre qui
traitera entre autres dossiers de cinq
pages sur les bestioles je m'appelle
toujours fabien olicard n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner à cette chaîne c'est
gratuit activer la cloche pour ne pas
rater les prochaines vidéos ici je vous
mets une vidéo sur l'origine du mythe
des vampires et si une vidéo sur le
trésor de la chouette d'or pensez aussi
à me suivre sur instagram c'est le seul
allah je publie plein de choses qui sont
complémentaires à mes vidéos et j'espère
que le prochain numéro de cure il vous
plaira autant que les précédents prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt
ciao